but you had like a thing to look forward
to with the sidewalk i had a light at
the end of the tunnel
and i knew if i got to the light
what's the worst that's gonna happen
just get to the light but at that point
like i again
i had a son i had a husband i had a
great company i have a great house i
have a nice car i have everything
why did i want to die every minute of
the day
i was at that point again
and i'm like this has got it something's
got to give
and so i went
and i got there
and
she
is
um
the most intense
beautiful divine
deity or entity or
visualization
whatever you want to deem ayahuasca as
is real
and she takes no prisoners
she shows you exactly what you need to
see
to help yourself
but she does not
discriminate against
whether you're ready or not if you've
ingested it she's coming for you
she's gonna be either gentle or she's
gonna beat your ass and sometimes it's
what you need but she does it in a way
that
is profound
so what were some memorable profound
moments for you what uh what what are
the places it took you
the people had you meet for the first
time
i got to be in a group of people who
didn't judge me or question my service
they just respected me
that was number one
so that group i lost
i just found again
um
big shocker i was the only woman there
again
seems to be the
the thing for me
and so i was surrounded by all these
special operators like these aren't like
normal soldiers like these guys that i'm
with are like
bronze star [ __ ] purple heart just
the coolest people
people i've always wanted to be like
that's my buddy now i can be like those
are my buddies like those [ __ ]
will go to bat for me they will bend
over backwards they will x fill me out
of anywhere they will take a bullet for
me
and these guys welcomed me in in a way i
didn't i didn't expect so that hit me
weird right off the get i was nervous
and now i was just felt at home for a
minute
and then when i stepped into ceremony
um
the first night because you do you do
three nights so we're like over like
friday saturday sunday the first night
i was so nervous and so anxious
because you go up in ceremony and your
the shamans come in and they they
cleanse themselves and then you get
served the
ayah individually you go up they give it
to you you can take your time and pray
you can do whatever you want then you
drink it
i was so just like
i got back to my mat and i sat there
and i was like trying to keep it in but
i could feel that like
heat come from my toes all the way up
and you're like your mouth starts to
water my
throat i'm gonna throw up
and i looked over to griff and i looked
at bishop and they're like
swallow it and i was like okay
and you can't talk or anything
so i like
my buddy um we call him the viking or
soul viking he looks like a viking his
head's tattooed he's
he's been on the show
he's so cool he's sitting directly
across like you and i and he can see me
he's looking at me and i'm throwing up
and
and i do it about three times and then
the last time he just saw me i couldn't
do it i just
i threw it up and so
i like to think that was her way of
easing me in so i didn't get like a full
punch to the face but i gotta let me
take your hand and show you what i'm
gonna show you we're gonna make you
better we're gonna take the pain away
aren't you supposed to eventually throw
up no matter what it's not supposed to
some people don't you purge yeah if
something's happening you're going
through something yeah you purge but it
doesn't have to happen but this i mean
within like the first 20 minutes no
okay this takes like you got to sit and
meditate
for or sit still basically and meditate
in the pitch black for about 45 minutes
before the effects even before you even
feel her
so it's very
so here she figured out the right dose
you need
well because i did the same dose as
everyone else
i think it was 20 mils which doesn't
seem like a lot
but when you've never done iodized
oh my god
so um
i felt like such a [ __ ] god i felt like
such a [ __ ]
okay that was the thought going through
your mind oh you just [ __ ] it all up
you ruined it you ruined this again you
couldn't do this right yeah
and so
at that point
um we we went through the meditation
part and the shamans were
they literally sing for like six hours
straight so you said that you take it
and then there's just you just you're
quietly listening to them meditate and
you wait and you wait
and you're in pitch black like can't see
this far in front of your face cool and
you have a little puke bucket
and then you have a little light that
has a red filter on it if you have to
get up to go to the bathroom to get out
of the you use that so you don't turn
lights on
and um
me i brought like what what no it's just
a cool visual of just a puke bucket and
a little light for the like i can
imagine these like little lights going
every once in a while and the rest is
just in darkness meditating with this
with the singing
it's it's so beautiful it's cool i'll
take you some time because trust me you
would
i
i wouldn't offer if it wasn't the group
i would trust
yeah that's in you had a very
interesting group so it's the the the
heroic hearts yeah
so that yeah this is my
jesse gave us all these journals they're
like you're gonna want these
so he gave us all these journals and now
this is like my bible like my work my
everything goes in this with me
everywhere it's just this like silent
reminder for me and so heroic hearts
does
fantastic work um i'll get into them
after
the thing with
this group is
there's such
care
it's not like go do aya and like you're
done there's like integration coaches
and there's like doctors and there's
like people to make sure that
you're doing the work because i is just
this is just the gate now you have to
take it and you have to implement it
into your life
people don't do that though did you do
uh like integration did you do
conversations with somebody did you talk
to you like is there a process to
because i've uh similar with philosophy
you mentioned i i've
as i understand it's exceptionally
beneficial for when you also do like
talk therapy like you couple that with
the integration in some form where you
talk through your experience and talk
through different things like that that
seems to be a really you know i need to
do that more with uh basically every
substance i take like if i get which
have been every once in a while known to
do a bit of vodka or whiskey or whatever
like do integration the next day
well what did you learn what did you get
from that what did you get because you
you learn a lot but you sometimes kind
of just move on and you celebrate that
that happened but like really kind of
think through it write it down yeah
that's important because that's what
this was
so the first night i'll give like a very
cause trust me we could spend a whole
podcast on both of the all three of
those nights but the first night the
biggest thing that happened for me is i
got to see my daughter
which was my first baby
and so people say well you know blah
blah blah [ __ ] you that was my daughter
and i'm very aware it was i'm very
conscious that it was
and at that point she just eased me in
enough
to let me know and showed me enough that
this wasn't it
this wasn't
the end-all be-all where you are right
now on this plane on this dimension in
this life this is
this is a flip and it is
it is so minuscule to the big picture
and so she really did that by she showed
me just a black and then like a crack
and then these vibrant colors that i
can't describe because there aren't
words alex gray does really great um
art and that is like been the closest
thing i've been able to find colors
he's a famous uh guy who does ayahuasca
and
he's an artist i think he's got stuff in
new york as well
but um
she just she eased me in
and gave me some relief and showed me
enough that i could go
i could wake up the next day and not
want to die the next day
and so what heroic heart said because it
gave us all these journals they're like
you know the next day you kind of wake
up
and you
you do
a meet like a meeting you do like a
circle all of us sit in a room and talk
about what just happened the night
before
people are crying and people are quiet
and you just listen and that's what you
do and
then you write on your free time so
after that it's like up to you what you
want to do do you want to just go walk
in the woods well i chose to go find a
fence post and lie on it for an hour
i'm not kidding i lied there and stared
up at these two eagles that were just in
like the i'll tell you where we were
after and you look you'll be like oh
okay i get it and then i found a forest
and i just walked up with my book
and i just
lied there
for hours
then she all of a sudden started giving
me what you call your downloads
so the stuff you learn
the stuff that you were all of a sudden
you're remembering and these messages
that come through and that's what this
is
what kind of things are we talking about
so my biggest thing that she tried to
reiterate to me at the beginning of
that first night was that i don't
breathe
i just
i don't
i don't breathe i don't [ __ ] breathe
at all i just one thing the next thing
the next thing the next thing the next
thing just to survive i don't take a
minute and breathe
and so she made
when i say she and i say it because it's
hard for people to understand but i
showed this to my husband i showed it to
my doctors and they're like
uh [ __ ] that's not you you don't write
like that you don't talk like that
so like you can flip through it
but it was like
i'll just give i'll just let lex read
for a second and just i'll just do here
let me do i'll do an ad for heroic
hearts heroic hearts
here i'll get my papers while you read
connect to her listen to her open to her
do you mind if i read some of these you
can read some of it yeah go right ahead
the dark has lifted judge my spelling
and i'll punch you read the face
well there's like um it's very
sporadic-y
sporadically written
it's okay to be still it's okay to be
quiet
this is a good like
and these are over a stretch of
that was the first the cup first couple
pages were from the first night
this was just that weekend i'm not just
there laying looking at the eagles
yeah with them with the pen just frantic
as well lex not like writing where
you're like oh i'm just writing it's
like i had to get it down or i was gonna
lose it
you are
warrior
you are power
you can
choose now
breathe now
be now
be present be warrior be strength
breathe
be the strength you are the strength
there's some soul-searching going on
here this is incredible
yeah we wait till you get to get in
there
she gets deep real aggressive like
crack the door
for i am the light
the giver the taker
i am warrior i am life i am air i am
water i am fire
i am light
this will this can this will this can
for i am warrior
for i am light and there's a leaf here
what's the story with the leaf
i don't know i was walking and every
single time over the over those three
days any time i like went for uh
a walk by myself
i would just hear like
take this like just almost like as if a
voice was standing there like you need
this take it take it with you and keep
it in your book keep it
ground you
and it just goes off this is from there
yeah it's cool to have
sort of it's almost like time travel
i have poppies from france too when i
did uh i did a 75th anniversary d-day
ride in france where we rode 600
kilometers on our road bikes for charity
and we landed on the beaches of juno on
the 75th and we got to go buy the poppy
fields
and i'm like covered in poppies
and i i have some in a in a book i don't
know why i do that i just
i do that
that's cool because like these are your
thoughts and those are the physical
items as it really helps transport to
that place somehow
let the light in let her in
and she would show me these visuals so
my drawings are just like
yeah there's drawings here
and you're seeing this stuff oh
yeah
i can't draw either so that's why
they're so i wish i could draw because
if only i could translate what i could
see
visually onto paper
and you're talking to her yeah
it's time i'm here to listen
is this
mama aya yeah we call her mama aya mama
aya
mama i see what who who are you seeing
is this a woman so for me at first it
was just eyes floating in the sky these
unbelievably gorgeous beautiful eyes
that i and i was like literally looking
up at the top of the year and i kept
going to myself is anyone else seeing
this
there's eyes in the sky
yeah yeah
and so
there's these eyes floating and they
just kept looking at me and i remember
when i kept telling myself like oh don't
worry about nothing there she would get
angry
i'm right here pay attention to me and
i'd be like
okay like forceful
like very forceful so at first it was
just the eyes
the second night
i'm crazy when i say this
great that's gonna be my clipping down
crazy
it's what i do when i get uncomfortable
i do weird hand gestures and movements
um voices i like it yeah i do yeah
uh you would hate to be in my office
because most of the day it's just
[Music]
this i love it weird lunges and
uncomfortable moments
she
turned me into a wolf
i i know i said it out loud i said i
hear it i said it yeah head to toe
and her takeaway for me was
i'm trying to be this pack leader i'm
trying to be this leader in my life i'm
trying to do these things but i'm going
about them the whole wrong way
so like when the shamans call you up to
do their special prayer over you
you go up you don't touch them they
flash their little light you see the
little light spot you walk to the light
you sit down on the light
and then my shaman he's so funny because
he's got this great tone in his voice he
goes
uh how you doing kelsey
and i'm like
um
so hi
yeah i have a problem um i'm a wolf and
i need it to stop
and he'd be like don't you worry girl i
got you you ready and i was like
uh-huh uh-huh and so i'm sitting there
cross-legged i've got my palms out like
this and i had a really traumatic
shoulder injury so i don't just sit
slanted like this my shoulders actually
permanently detached and no one in the
world will touch it or fix it my
collarbone comes out my back here nice
and i don't have any collarbone here
okay so nobody will fix it no one will
touch it even i've had specialists i've
had surgeries no one will do anything
with it so i'm permanently
down and forward so i
slouch
um
it's horrible
so before i go functionally too oh
there's nothing i can't do a pull-up
anymore oh
so weak
oh wow oh you should i'll show you how
to do a push-up after you'll [ __ ]
throw up an embarrassment
yeah it's bad so before i though chronic
pain like had to drink a bottle of cbd
every day just the pain is so bad
because the trauma in it was so bad the
surgery went wrong
the collarbone dissipated and no longer
exists like there's just and they're not
sure how i lift things with it and do
stuff with it it's like over
compensation everywhere like my
the my back fli like um
my truck my scapula like flares out
where it's i'm all messed up from it and
so i was in chronic pain so he's praying
over me and all of a sudden all i feel
is this arm just start
just
[ __ ] vibrating and my hair is really
long and i feel somebody grab the back
of my ponytail and snap my head back
like this and it felt like something was
coming out of my throat like being
pulled
out of me
and the takeaway that i end up in the
whole the rest of the night there was a
million other things but the takeaway
was
you no longer need to bite you may only
show your teeth you can be the leader
that you want to be
you do not always have to
be the traditional type of leader you
can be in the back of the pack you have
to watch the rest around you
be
mindful of those around you instead of
just being up front be
be behind as well make sure that
everything that you're doing is all
being looked after
because my thing was i will rip your
[ __ ] head off if you just say the
wrong thing to me before
the whole thing was you can just show
your teeth and that is more than enough
stop trying to be
stop trying to overcompensate you don't
need to do that any longer
and then i had this weird astral
projection thing happen
like where i was in my house
and there were these flyers all over my
husband and my son
and like
i went ham on them i like shredded them
to pieces like i was this protector
and
it's crazy because the guys told me
after like someone would be like
there were fliers all over you the whole
night they were just all over you and
i'm like i was snarling when i was
sitting there like the shaman had to be
like
i need you to try to calm your breathing
after i could but before like i was like
attacking things beside me
that people could see and i could see
but
couldn't wrap my brain around that they
were real like it was
[ __ ] weird
this is crazy man that's day two that's
day two
and so what's so what's the big takeaway
there my takeaway was i needed to be
i needed to
stop trying to
stop trying to push everything too hard
stop trying to force everything it's all
going to come it's all going to happen
but you are
you are too aggressive you are too
you're trying so hard that you're
missing you're missing everything else
got it
that's just uh trying to be a better
human kind of thing right
this is this is getting intense
aggressive
yeah i get to grasp
i mean there's love and light still it
gets loving light
love and light the warrior within is
calm
she will test you daily show her respect
so that's what i mean you've read my
book you know i don't write like that
yeah this is strange
see god you get it
because people don't understand what i
say i didn't
i don't feel like i wrote that i feel
like she gave me like i re reread this
all of the time
so i i wonder i mean obvi well not
obviously but
this is somehow part of you
i think it's a part of me obviously
reconnect reconnecting you somehow to
that part it kind of is incredible to
think of what are the things that are
part of us that we haven't really
explored you know and there's so many
we just get nature to connect to her
feel her flow through them
use them for the strength for each day
and your challenge will present itself
love light breathe
sorry i have too much hair
never enough i used to have long hair
what about day three so day three is the
the stuff i talked about on jocko
when i got taken over to the other side
i almost missed that night too
i almost missed that ceremony
i got a false positive on my covet test
and i got a call
from the medical clinic that night
being like you need to come in you got a
false positive on your kova test and
if you're going to travel you have to
we got to figure this out you got to
come do blood work you got to come do
you know whatever it is you need to do
if you want to get home but you got to
come do something and so
i didn't think i was going to be in
ceremony i had to leave so i left
and
you know
they waited
they waited for me
and so
i think the biggest takeaway from all of
this for me was
this isn't it it
this isn't everything this isn't
the end-all be-all
you can fight through this this is
possible it's gonna take work it's gonna
be [ __ ] hard it's worth it though
and if you just keep going the right
direction everything that i wrote down
everything every goal it'll happen
you